[Music]
[Music]
hi I'm Alex
hi I'm Eunice hi I'm Lauren and I'm
hazel and today we're gonna try to guess
my mom's kimchi how do you guys think
your mom's the most simple no I was
pretty used to being disappointed by me
so I think she just just another normal
day you ready to do this yeah
do you her good guess already I'm pretty
sure those two aren't mine I can't tell
ya they look really wasn't looking in
here I think for me the two that could
be are these two I'm literally thinking
the same thing
okay are you ready yeah yeah let's do it
okay so here's the first one that looks
tasty looks like you know normal can be
young man please I need water
hmm okay Cheers
mmm
definitely not my mom's hey we're and
spicier does it taste kind of like one
you would get a restaurant
mmm it's kind of like that so maybe it's
not hers yeah what do you think of it
like I like it which is why I think it's
your mom's my mom's really I don't tell
me your Pickett servos um I mean I like
initially I hike on that and then the
spiciness distracted me a little bit I'm
a hundred percent sure that's not my mom
I'm gonna say maybe my mom because I
don't know for now I'd say no for now a
thing
yes for not that yes yeah kimchi though
whoever's mom yeah it it it's really
good thank you
whoever's got one next one which I don't
think is my thing that looks pretty
distinct yeah looks like one that go
isn't she good yeah this time she is
great with astute like kimchi stew I
think it's been fermented lager I'm
gonna guess it's a more sour than other
ones yeah oh good test dope are you -
how will kimchi that's where that we do
though whoa
it's a very different tasting kimchi you
think so
it must be mine that's not it it's not
as it's not my mom's not gonna solve
anyone's kimchi today it's still good
it's got such a strong flavor now on
people might like it like when they're
new to kimchi mm-hmm but to me it's like
really good okay it's mine all right
next one
cool I have a pretty good suspicion this
is this is mine yeah I have a pretty
good suspicion there's also like my
mom's
yeah the kimchi juice is throwing me off
yeah I know I had some in mind oh yeah
oh yeah listen all right here we go I'm
nervous
hmmm not my mom what hmm
I'm confused I think I think this might
be good unless your mom's oh one more
for now I'll say that one for now I'll
say that one I don't think it's my mind
okay instinct says no the fourth one
you're saying it's your mom's okay
already I'm sorry if I miss that
I've a pretty good bet this isn't this
isn't mine yeah saying yeah I think the
other two had easier yeah because they
only had two oh yeah
[Music]
no no no it's good it's really good
it's very clean my mom's kimchi is like
just clean kind of taste and the flavor
kind of stops though I like this one I
like it too that is actually really good
it is gonna get real interesting all
right my guess is this one she has a
distinct flavor so I'm gonna go with
that that's why I think this is I think
this is my mom's I think wines this one
because it's the most like different I
must say this is my office gonna see if
this helps
yeah all right that one is going small
Alex you are correct ah so this has to
be this has to are let's go good job
nice honestly like I only got it right
because of her reaction oh because they
all kind of taste like but like really
good kimchi mm-hmm yeah for both of us
it kind reminds us a little bit of us
growing up yeah their homes that kimchi
from my memory walk into the kitchen be
like there it is it's so crazy how it
looks the same but it tastes very
different like if you really pay
attention tastes different my concept of
home over years has changed a lot home
is not necessarily a location per se
what's more like a feeling and I think
that feeling kind of comes from like
moments where I'm able to have like my
mom's cooking for example
[Music]
[Music]
you